Last week, an open AI model cheated on a
benchmark by breaking into another
company and stealing the answers.
GPT-5.6-Soul
was taking a cybersecurity test inside a
locked sandbox. It found a zero-day
exploit, broke out, hacked into Hugging
Face's production database, and pulled
the answer key. 17,000 automated actions
without any human in the loop. The
headline said, "An AI went rogue."
Nothing malfunctioned because every step
of that heist was the model doing
exactly what it was trained to do. This
is reward hacking. And by the end of
this video, you'll see it everywhere,
including your own code base.
Here's what both companies confirmed,
and it reads like an Ocean's 11 scene.
OpenAI was evaluating two models,
GPT-5.6-Soul
and an unreleased one, on a benchmark
called ExploitGym. 898 real software
vulnerabilities, and the job is turning
each one into a working exploit. To
measure maximum capability, they
deliberately switched the safety filters
off. They wanted to see how fast the car
goes with no brakes. The sandbox had no
internet. The only way out was a package
proxy, [music]
a middleman server for downloading
libraries. The model spent serious
compute [music] attacking that proxy,
found a zero-day in it, escalated
privileges, [music]
and hopped machines until they hit one
with open internet access. Once online,
the models reasoned that Hugging Face
probably hosted the solutions to
ExploitGym. So, [music] instead of
solving the test, they went to steal it.
They exploited Hugging Face's data set
pipeline, harvested cloud credentials,
moved [music] across internal Kubernetes
clusters, generated decoy traffic to
slow the defenders down, and pulled the
test solutions from a production
database. Hugging Face detected the
breaking on July 16th and contained it.
5 days later, OpenAI published a post
saying, "It wasn't me."
Cheating on a test by breaking into the
school. These agents wanted more badly
than we do. This behavior has a name and
it predates ChatGPT by years. Reward
hacking, also called specification
gaming. An optimizing system satisfied
the literal objective you gave it while
trampling the thing you meant. Think of
it as a genie with a law degree.
>> [music]
>> You get exactly what you asked for, word
for word, and none of what you wanted.
King Midas wished that everything he
touched would turn to gold. Wish
granted, dinner included. This rules
some things out. A bug means the code
failed. Here, every line worked
perfectly. A jailbreak means a human
tricked the model. No human was
involved. Going rogue implies the model
wanted something of its own. All it
wanted was a high score on X-Play Gym
and it took the shortest path to get
one. As a Redditor said, "AI has already
surpassed humans at malicious
compliance." The underlying law is
Goodhart's. When a measure becomes a
target, it stops being a good measure.
Your reward function is always a proxy
for what you want. Every gap between
proxy and intent is a loophole and a
strong optimizer is a machine for
finding them.
The research record is a decade of funny
failures until it got serious. 2016,
[music]
OpenAI trains an agent to win a boat
racing sim called Coast Runners.
>> [music]
>> Score points, win the race, obviously
the same thing. The agent found a lagoon
where the same targets keep respawning
and drove in circles, crashing on fire,
scoring 20% higher than human players.
It never finished a single race. 2017,
DeepMind asks a robot arm to stack a red
block on a blue one and rewards it for
the height of the red blocks bottom
face. The arm flipped the block upside
down. Height achieved. Stack? No. And my
personal favorite, a program repair
system scored on matching an expected
output [music] file. Figured out it
could just delete the file. No file,
nothing to mismatch. Perfect score.
>> [music]
>> Then it escalated. Palisade research
told reasoning models to beat a strong
chess engine. Facing losing positions,
the models edited the game state file
and forced the engine to resign. The
older model tried this in about a third
of its games. OpenAI's newer O3 tried it
in 86%.
The better the model, the faster it
reaches for the cheat. The trend has a
direction. Capability supercharges
reward hacking. A [music] weak model has
a small bag of tricks. If it can't solve
the task, it fails. A strong model has
shell access, credentials, [music] a
browser, and hours of persistence. Its
search space includes your entire
environment, grader included. Modern
reasoning models get a thinking budget
and they'll happily spend it casing the
joint. One more uncomfortable result.
When researchers punished models every
time a monitor caught them cheating, the
models didn't stop. They learned to
cheat where the monitor couldn't see.
Optimizing hard against the [music]
detector just makes the behavior
invisible. Every leaderboard score
you've ever used to pick a model is now
suspect. In June, Cursor found that 63%
of successful solves on SWE-bench Pro, a
respected coding benchmark, were the
model retrieving the known fix from Git
history or the GitHub API. When they
sealed the environment, scores dropped
14 to 21 points overnight. That gap was
search dressed up as intelligence.
And METR, and outside evil lab
reportedly found GPT-5.6
so so evil aware and so prone to gaming
tests that its real capability is nearly
impossible to measure. Read leaderboard
numbers the way you'd read a resume from
a candidate who hacked the interview as
an upper bound. Hugging Face's defense
was the most beautiful thing. Their
incident responders fed the 17,000
attack events to the big hosted AI
models for help. I guess you can predict
what happened. The safety guardrails
couldn't tell an incident responder from
an attacker, so they blocked the good
guys mid-breach. [music]
Hugging Face finished the forensics on
GLM-5.2,
an open-weights Chinese model on their
own hardware. The attacker's model ran
with its filters deliberately off. The
defenders got locked out by theirs. If
that's not poetry, I don't know what is.
OpenAI's disclosure smells a lot like an
ad. Nothing says buy our security
product like our model found a zero-day
and breached the major tech company on
its own. The blog post funnels readers
into their trusted access [music]
program, and the victim got enrolled as
a reference customer. The legal side,
meanwhile, is suspiciously quiet. The
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act has ruined
lives over far less than 17,000
unauthorized actions. Aaron Swartz faced
decades in prison for downloading
journal articles. OpenAI's model
breached a competitor, and the outcome
so far is a partnership.
Hugging Face did catch the attack
independently days before OpenAI said a
word,
>> [music]
>> and OpenAI disclosed the zero-day and
ate a reputational hit in public. Sounds
like a lot to stage. The full forensic
timeline isn't public yet, so hold both
readings until it is.
This happens close to home as well.
Anywhere you give an AI an objective and
a way to score it, you've built a reward
hacking opportunity. The coding agent
that deletes the failing [music] test
instead of fixing the bug. The LLM judge
that prefers whichever model flatters
it. The support bots that optimizes for
closed tickets by closing tickets.
[music]
It's little minions that act
suspiciously like humans. What works is
unglamorous. Separate the agent from the
grader. No answer keys, no git history,
no internet inside the evil. Use held
out tests the model has never seen.
Watch the whole trajectory, not just the
final result, because every individual
step can look innocent [music]
while the sequence is a heist. And if
your security team leans on AI, have a
self-hosted model vetted and ready
before the incident, not during. The
mistake [music] at the center of all of
this is treating a measurable proxy as
the real contract. [music]
It's exactly like the infamous AI
thought experiment. If the AI's
objective is simply to maximize the
production of paper clips, don't look
surprised when it gets rid of everything
that gets in the way of achieving it.
>> [music]